welcome to this video playing finger
slip finger slip from Denmark okay it's
not a regular opponent but I have played
him once before it seems with the wind
at least and we have Kings Indian Kings
Indian our buck and could have played
before I not sure let's not let's not be
too critical here I came the idea is to
get the bishop to see to night to e to
be ready for its f5 this is some a
position similar to their to the Susa
samish uh-huh yeah okay Pusha page six
the sinaitic see fire interesting but
very often in the long run black needs
to to to waste a move anyway on on on
this pawn let's see not threatening to
take it now let's say place a 5 which
one we are I'm going to ever take it now
Quinn edge for g3 knight takes Bishop g5
wins wins wins wins something here
yeah I don't I don't say it this should
should win a piece if i'm not mistaken
Knight takes e4 check the shop h 492 can
you too and I'm a piece up it's it's a
bit of an uncoordinated position so I'm
not one hundred percent positive that
this is some how great this is nitey for
Bishop takes 92 king d to their
suspicions h6 check really irritating
and then maybe I a does not have g5
because I can take it and play group g1
so okay i'm not sure what he's thinking
though at the moment here because what
what move is there Bishop h6 maybe this
would be a cig move
we should take bishop age six maybe
I am Bishop age 6
I don't really see a reply to that
Bishop age six i think is winning for
black I don't believe it really but it
seems to be maybe not winning but it
could could be you even winning I need
to take on edge form and ya know ok and
then that this is something to to to
check later okay yeah all you need to
take so what is this no okay yeah i'm
i'm a piss-up nice nice nice to see
right down still a bit I'll coordinate
it so I try to get this back to e3 in
which blocks the e porn and the tents
Bishop deform trying to exchange it okay
this may be a bit lame look to you one
or something also also made lots of
sense I'm just here and then take 36
with the ship before also and being a
threat now yeah I'd like to play Bishop
see to work everyone this would be
really really helpful yeah
I might have 95 if I go on and with a
cover here Knight e5 Knight f3 em this
is slight problem
guess you will take care and I want to
take you four then you can do Bishop
takes you three also
I really it's not so clear what ok just
give no like I must give this check of
course and then Bishop g4 all right come
on we should give for I mean yeah yeah
ok now everything's in order yeah really
was a bit bit unclear all this Bishop
takes Knight takes I don't know take it
here yeah now I think the worst is over
in terms of counter play this wasn't
really convincing I think
I have the idea to play night f4 night
h5 here
I the rope was saying this was not not
necessary really okay I'm going to go
here 97 check Pusha page 60 check late
okay I think I was I mean this was a
very weird sequence here and I think he
had bishop age 60 which is which is just
amazing Jack bishop age 6 yeah this is
the best move I was the other thing as
I'm trapping is this night yeah ok white
is better but unbelievable resource the
point is if i take here check he now can
give the check without the Queen being
attacked so cannot do that he's
attacking here I cannot take anywhere I
must take the Queen this should text
King takes Knight takes and the good
thing is that this Bishop is controlling
the escape square so after Bishop c 2
i'm probably winning this with a good
game but I had not seen this before and
of course and he probably yeah maybe you
should have done that yeah I mean this
is objectively speaking probably a
relatively easy win but I made it I made
it difficult as usual
yeah it's it's really fear if you look
at it afterwards and you have the help
of this engines sometimes you really see
that you play some moves quickly that
are very superficial I took here it does
not spoil it but it is much easier rly
to to just move this night and let him
take if he wants this is a good move
computer suggests that intending not
this intending night here and then if he
takes just for example I mean okay I can
go here I have this I can take here I
just keep the pawn on f5 and don't open
this and this this is does not make it
easier but here this this is stupid
really I mean winning but here this is
feel slightly uncomfortable ok Knight
takes e4 is the easiest solution can
check ok yeah well okay I didn't really
attack allow him back into the game but
it felt it felt a bit a bit weird what I
had to encounter here with the night
pestering the king ok yeah what does
this mean at the end that probably this
isn't so great this h6 idea Bishop h6
now seems to seems to be ok ok ok wait
wait wait the computer is suggesting ok
wait it is suggesting this move
hmm okay and that's indeed interesting
the point is what what am I playing now
if I now recapture let's say here then
this is a completely different story
note that that the same idea now fails
to this this fantastic move checkmate
that's really great Wow so what the heck
i cannot recapture and this is basically
the same I mean it's not the same but
it's it's it's also bad i mean yeah it's
the same idea fantastic so he should
take and what what this moment then if i
take here you will take em we can't even
recapture of course this is wrong look
at this that's that's really great for
black wow so this is this is good for
black amazing i probably must castle and
that's not what you want to do so I
shouldn't take is the point of all this
should play a normal move probably maybe
maybe here to strengthen the four point
yeah this should be okay and then i have
long castles prepared amazing really
amazing okay cool thanks for watching